und ich rufe auf die tagesordnungspunkte
25a und 25b erste beratung ist von der
bundesregierung eingebrachten
gesetzentwurfs zur stärkung von kindern
und jugendlichen sowie beratung des
antrags der fraktionen der fdp mit dem
titel § 94 absatz 6 des achten buch ist
achten buch sozialgesetzbuch abschaffen
bessere chancen auf ein selbstbestimmtes
leben auch für pflegekinder für die
aussprache ist eine dauer von 30 minuten
bis 19
so und ja gesehen wie das ministerium
für familie frauen senioren oder
polizist schon auf dem weg wieder zum
pult es geht um mehr schutz mehr
unterstützung für kinder und jugendliche
in pflegefamilien aber auch in
betreuungseinrichtungen oder heimen ich
freue mich dass wir heute gleich zwei
familienpolitisch große und bedeutsame
gesetzgebungsvorhaben hier im plenum
beraten und besprechen können und das
ist ein gutes signal gerade in dieser
zeit für die familien in deutschland
wir haben hier heute die erste lesung
unseres kinder und jugend stärker
ausgesetzt sein vorhaben dass wir lange
vorbereitet haben das auch in der
vergangenen legislatur schon einmal
einen anlauf gemacht hat und für mich
war es die aufgabe als ich ministerin
wurde dieses großprojekt zu einem guten
abschluss zu bringen und wir haben alles
getan damit es dieses mal wirklich
gelingen kann und wir haben einen
umfangreichen beteiligungsprozess
angestoßen unter dem motto mitreden und
mitgestalten 9000 beiträge sind
eingegangen sind in dieses
gesetzgebungsverfahren eingeflossen und
wir haben mit dieser reform der kinder
und jugendhilfe die wir heute im plenum
das erste mal beraten nach unseren
großen flaggschiffen gute kita gesetz
starke familiengesetz jetzt ein weiteres
flaggschiff der kinder und jugendpolitik
in deutschland und wenn wir
es fragen über wen wir hier reden wir
reden über rund 1,1 millionen kinder und
jugendliche die in familien leben die
nicht alleine zurechtkommen diese
familien brauchen unsere unterstützung
sie erhalten hilfen zur erziehung dafür
gibt der staat rund 13 milliarden euro
pro jahr aus und allein 240.000 dieser
kinder leben in einrichtungen oder bei
pflegefamilien und führt sie alle sind
wir verantwortlich und deshalb freue ich
mich dass wir heute diesen schritt gehen
können weil wir verbesserungen für die
kinder und jugendlichen einleiten die es
besonders schwer haben in deutschland
und ich weiß dass auch viele von ihnen
als abgeordnete mitgeholfen haben weil
diese beteiligungsprozess und dabei
waren sich eingebracht haben fachlich
beraten haben dafür auch ihnen die
intensiv dabei waren vielen herzlichen
dank
wir stellen unser gesetz unter fünf
große begriffe schützen stärken helfen
unterstützen und beteiligen es geht um
einen besseren kinder und jugendschutz
es geht um die stärkung von familien in
pflegeeinrichtungen oder in
pflegefamilien die kinder und
jugendlichen die dort untergebracht sind
in einrichtungen der erziehungshilfe es
geht darum dass wir endlich hilfen aus
einer hand für kinder mit und ohne
behinderung gewähren es geht um mehr
prävention vor ort und es geht darum
dass junge menschen aber auch ihre
eltern und familien sowohl die
pflegefamilien als auch die
herkunftsfamilien besser beteiligt
werden
an der kinder- und jugendhilfe an den
dingen die sie betreffen und die
einrichtung von deutschland bei den
ombudsstellen ist zb ein instrument was
mir dafür sehr wichtig ist auch die
reduzierung der kosten heranziehen wenn
pflege kinder oder kinder die in
einrichtungen leben einen ferienjob
machen etwas selbst tun dass sie eben
nicht 75 prozent ihres einkommens
abgeben müssen sondern es umgekehrt ist
dass sie 75 prozent behalten dürfen und
nur 25
gezogen werden diese größten betreuung
ist einer von vielen aspekten das geht
aber um viel mehr wir wollen den
kinderschutz verbessern wir werden die
kommunikation zwischen kinder- und
jugendhilfe und ärzten verbessern
wir haben ganz starke rückmeldung dass
das ein entscheidender punkt ist uneben
kindeswohlgefährdung abzuwenden und wir
sorgen dafür dass die familien wie
kinder mit behinderung haben einen
festen ansprechpartner bekommen und das
ist getragen von der überzeugung dass
jedes kind erstmal ein kind ist und dass
wir schauen wie dieses kind in der
kinder und jugendhilfe die beste
unterstützung bekommen kann und dass wir
nicht die kinder schon vorher sortieren
nach behinderung und sie dann in einem
anderen kreis beraten und betreuen und
damit meine damen und herren verändern
wir die kinder und jugendliche für das
nächste jahrzehnt wir unterstützen
kinder und jugendliche beim booten
aufwachsen
dieses ist ein riesiges vorhaben ich bin
sehr stolz darauf dass wir betragen sind
von der fachszene von denjenigen die
betroffenen sind von all denen die in
ländern in verbänden beteiligt waren und
die sich freuen auf dieses gesetz darauf
warten dass es endlich kommt weil es
echte verbesserungen bringen wird und
ich werde auch sagen aus meiner
persönlichen erfahrungen als ehemalige
bürgermeisterin hier in einem brennpunkt
in berlin
ich bin froh dass dieses gesetz kommt
und ich habe die familien vor augen
denen es helfen wird und insofern ist
heute wirklich ein guter tag für die
familienpolitik in deutschland
franziska zum entwurf der
bundesregierung zum kinder und jugend
erstarkung des gesetz- und sie hat auch
noch mal angesprochen den langen dialog
prozess im vorfeld mit sehr vielen
beteiligten mit umfangreichen
abstimmungen unter anderem mit anderen
ministerien aber auch mit den
bundesländern mit verbänden und
betroffenen
und wir haben das im interview heute
morgen ja auch schon mal angesprochen
möglicherweise auch durchaus stilbildend
für andere dem gesetzentwürfe oder
politische maßnahmen und entscheidungen
hier geht es jetzt weiter mit johannes
huber aus der fdp-fraktion liebe
landsleute das vorliegen der kinder und
jugend stärkung gesetz löst ein
wechselbad der gefühle aus sie machen
dort fortschritte wo sie rationalität
und pragmatismus weiten lassen versagen
aber leider umso mehr wo ihre
ideologischen fantasien mit ihren gut
mit ihnen durchgehen
sie machen etwa fortschritte wenn es um
die überprüfungen der einrichtungen der
kinder und jugendhilfe geht
sie schaffen die möglichkeit dass diese
endlich dass dieser endlich von den
zuständigen behörden auch unangemeldet
geprüft werden können weiß doch bisher
das muss man sich auf der zunge zergehen
lassen eine hinreichende absurdität dass
es deutlich einfacher war eine
unangekündigte überprüfung der
lebensmittelkontrolle in einer
gastronomie zu unternehmen als jene auf
die finger zu schauen sie sich unser
wertvollstes gut kümmern nämlich die
kinder der große schönheitsfehler ihre
konstruktion besteht jedoch in der von
ihnen nicht bis zum ende gedachten
funktionen der vertrauensperson
so soll jedes kind und jeder jugendliche
in einer solchen einrichtung das recht
haben eine vertrauensperson zu einem
gespräch mit der kontrollierenden
behörde mitzunehmen was sicherlich gut
gemeint ist kann in der praxis aber
fatale folgen haben
stellen wir uns beispielsweise kind vor
dass sich in einer wohneinrichtung
befindet dieses kind wird am schlimmsten
aber nicht ausgeschlossenen fall leider
ein opfer sexuellen missbrauchs durch
einen mitarbeiter dieser einrichtung
nun ist dieser mitarbeiter aber selbst
reden darüber im bilde
dass sein opfer das sogenannte recht auf
das beisein einer vertrauensperson in
einem gespräch mit der kontrollbehörde
hat er wird also mit hilfe der macht
konstellation
in diesen einrichtungen versuchen das
kind dazu zu bringen dass es ihnen im
falle des falles mit an den
verhandlungstisch setzt somit würden
angst und täter mit am tisch sitzen
durch die bloße anwesenheit würde auch
das gespräch kontrolliert bei diesen
erheblichen missständen in den
einrichtungen werden die dafür
verantwortlichen über dieses einfallstor
versuchung die gespräche zu manipulieren
und für das kind in dieser so wichtigen
situationen den notausgang versperren
hoffentlich habe ich sie davon überzeugt
dass sie es bei der richtigen maßnahmen
belassen
der unangekündigte überprüfungen sie
sollten ihre teilweise ideologische
haltung aber auch in einem anderen punkt
zugunsten eine wirklich wertvollen
lösung überdenken
das kinder und jugend stärkung gesetz
wird nämlich ausgerechnet bei der
wahrscheinlich verletzlichsten gruppe
unserer gesellschaft zum kinder und
jugend gefährdungs gesetz nämlich bei
den kindern und jugendlichen mit
behinderung
sie leben sie auf den altar über
gleichmacherei dabei sind es doch vor
allem dieser jungen menschen die unsere
besondere aufmerksamkeit verdienen
deren spezifische bedürfnisse wir
berücksichtigen und denen wir auch
spezialisierte und differenzierte
lösungen anbieten müssen
sie zieren aber alle register oder
wollen es zumindest machen die ihnen die
bundeskompetenz zulässt um ihre
ideologie der inklusion um jeden preis
durchzusetzen damit sie mich nicht
falsch verstehen inklusion kann sinnvoll
und von großer mehrwert seien aber
kinder die aufgrund ihrer behinderung
besondere förderung auch benötigen
benötigen sie in ihrer besten und
spezialisierten form unser ziel als afd
ist es diese jungen menschen auf ein
leben mit möglichst viele
selbstbestimmung vorzubereiten und ihre
bedürfnisse in den mittelpunkt zu
stellen um sie dadurch optimal zu
fördern
wir brauchen mehr spezialisierung statt
gleichmacherei
wir brauchen mehr individualität für
mehr freiheit und bessere lebensqualität
lassen sie also zum schluss ihre
ideologie zu gunsten dieser menschen
fallen die auf rationale entscheidungen
mehr als alle anderen angewiesen sind
dafür setzen wir uns jedenfalls ein
als alternative für deutschland soweit
also johannes huber aus der spd-fraktion
zum kinder und jugend der stärkung
gesetze dass die bundesregierung hier
vorgelegt hat und wir weisen sie darauf
hin dass wir diese debatte in ein paar
minuten zumindest vorübergehend
verlassen
denn es steht ein anderer wichtiger
punkt an eine pressekonferenz mit dem
bundesgesundheitsminister und rk ii
präsident lothar wieler es geht
natürlich um die aktuelle lage das wird
uns auch in zukunft noch ein bisschen
weiter verfolgen deswegen die präferenz
oder die priorität führt zu dieser
pressekonferenz mit den neuesten daten
12 hören wir noch ein bisschen marcus
weinberg zudem familienpolitischen
sprecher der unionsfraktion
ja es ist schon ein statement der
regierungsfraktionen dass sie zwei große
familien kinder jugend politische themen
heute anmelden und zwar um 9 uhr also
zur primetime zur besten sendezeit
das heißt also damit wird auch deutlich
dass wir als koalition die
familienpolitischen themen da setzen wo
sie hingehören an die wichtigste stelle
das parlament ist und es auch zeichen
einer gewissen haltung die wir haben wir
haben gerade debattiert über die
lebenssituation von stabilen familien es
darum geht die stabilen familien
stichwort elterngeld ihr leben für ihre
kinder auch weiterentwickeln können und
jetzt in dieser phase reden wir aber
auch mal über die situation über die
kinder und familien in schwierigen
herausfordernden situationen sind denn
und das ist ja unsere haltung wir wollen
familien stärken denn pflege und
erziehung obliegt ja zuvörderst den
eltern aber es gibt situationen
lebenssituation von kindern jugendlichen
und familien da brauchen sie die
unterstützung der gemeinschaft des
staates des nachtwächter staates und das
ist das was im kinder und jugend
stärkung des gesetz jetzt deutlich
verändert werden soll denn so schlimm
ist ist aber muss leider erwähnen wir
haben viele situationen von kindern die
wir in deutschland erleben werden wir
hier 35 minuten debattieren
treiber drei familien kinder aus dieser
familie geholt weil sie missbrauch oder
gewalt erleben und das darf uns als
familie politiker nicht ruhen lassen
auch die kinder und die familien weiter
zu stärken
und wir wissen bei diesem gesetz das ist
ein hochsensibles thema ist die
lebenssituation von kindern es geht um
junge menschen die wir fördern wollen
benachteiligungen abbauen wollen eltern
beraten und unterstützen wollen ob zu
hause ob in pflegschaften oppenheim
das sind die themen die mit diesem
gesetz jetzt eine deutliche eine gute
reform mit sich bringe und ist deshalb
wichtig und war uns immer wichtig dass
dieses ein des kurses und ein gesetz das
nicht politisiert werden darf oder über
eine ideologie betrachtet werden muss
sondern das ist etwas was diejenigen die
in dieser in diesem politikfeld
verantwortung haben gemeinsam entwickeln
soll deswegen stehe ich der ministerin
zu das war ein guter erster prozess das
war uns auch wichtig dass verbände
mitgenommen wenn das die beteiligten
mitgenommen benannt werden möglichst
vielen personen gruppen die sich um die
kinder und jugendlichen kümmern auch
hören wo einiges im argen liegt aber
auch klar eine positionierung haben für
die nächsten jahre wie wir mit diesem
gesetz dann auch das erreichen was die
leitgedanken auszeichnet nämlich einen
besseren schutz von kindern und
jugendlichen kinder und jugendliche
stärken familien stärken aus einer hand
prävention stärken und die beteiligung
auch von kindern jugendlichen und eltern
stärken
aber bei der ersten lesung bleibt man ja
auch dazu zu sagen es gibt noch dinge
die etwas besser sein müssen
wir haben gerade erfahren beim
elterngeld wie gut und klug es ist wenn
sich das parlament mit einmischt und
gute vorlagen und etwas besser machen
deswegen möchte ich 34 punkte ansprechen
die aus meiner aus unserer sicht noch zu
diskutieren sind als erstes das thema
heimaufsicht also die fragestellung auch
wie sieht es aus mit dem
betriebserlaubnis und wann darf ein heim
aufmachen und wann muss es auch
geschlossen werden
da ist schon wichtig und das sagen wir
ganz deutlich dass wir nicht nur nicht
nur nach aktenlage uns das anschauen
wollen sondern es gibt die es geht das
prinzip der örtlichen prüfung der
unangekündigten prüfungen bei wir sehen
wollen wie leben die kinder in heimen
und wir hatten leider in der
vergangenheit
es ist die ausnahmslos an dieser stelle
auch mal sagen wir haben eine
hervorragende kinder und jugendhilfe und
wir reden wenn wir jetzt kritisch sehen
nur über die außen an die wenigen
ausnahmen aber wie gesagt das betrifft
immer die lebenssituation von kindern
und deswegen ist es auch unser ansinnen
dieses zu überprüfen und auch die frage
wann spricht man denn mit kindern und
jugendlichen und werden diese erschwert
mit dem einverständnis der
personensorgeberechtigten und da haben
sie leider das nicht richtig formuliert
es geht um allgemeine sprachen beim
sexuellen missbrauch bei sexualisierter
gewalt ist es nicht so dass dann
derjenige der das ding kind angetan hat
mit dabei ist das war ein bisschen faken
das muss man gerade gestellt wenn man
richtig gestellt werden
es geht aber grundsätzlich tatsächlich
bei der frage wer gespräche mit den
kindern und jugendlichen darum möglichst
viel zu erfahren wie diese kinder und
jugendlichen die situation in der
unterbringung wahrnehmen zweiter punkt
sind die wohnformen die gemeinsamen
wohnformen nach § 19
da würden wir uns schon wünschen frau
ministerin dass wir überlegen wie wir
diesen § 19 der momentan nicht angefasst
wird wie wir den insoweit anfassen
können zum beispiel durch die
hinzuziehung des anderen elternteils bei
einem aufenthalt nach § 19
und dann ist meine damen und das tut mir
jetzt leid dass ich in diese reedereien
platzen muss aber wir haben ihn
angekündigte pressekonferenz mit jens
spahn dem bundesgesundheitsminister und
lothar wieler dem präsidenten des robert
koch instituts und die zahlen von
infektionen sind zwar rückläufig aber
immer noch nicht niedrig genug und
außerdem haben wir eine extra deutlich
und hat starke im freibad und am montag
einen impf gipfel so dass wir jetzt mal
ganz schnell dem bundestag verlassen und
drüber gehen in die
bundespressekonferenz zum
bundesgesundheitsminister stichwort
rausing first stichwort auch
modellprojekte die in deutsche momentan
gut funktionieren hier können wir uns
durchaus auch vorstellen dass man so
etwas im sozialgesetzbuch acht verankert
stichwort thema obdachlosigkeit und das
thema jugend wohnungslosigkeit vierter
punkt und da geht es auch um das thema
inobhutnahmen es wird schon wichtig
seien auch mal zu hinterfragen warum
gibt es eigentlich so viele
inobhutnahmen
und was sind die gründe die dazu führen
dass ein jugendamt entscheidet ein kind
in obhut zudem noch einmal wir reden
über 50.000 kinder cuxhaven die stadt
cuxhaven peile das sind steht die haben
50.000 einwohner und jedes jahr könnte
man sagen wird die stadt cuxhaven in
obhut genommen und deswegen müssen wir
uns fragen warum ist denn das so sind
das entscheidung des jugendamtes die
erklärbar sind wurde sind entscheidungen
die nicht zu erklären sind und deswegen
herr präsident komme ich zum schluss
es ist eine große freude einen guten
entwurf zu haben das ist jetzt
tatsächlich ein flaggschiff und hier ist
es das wichtigste dass königssee mit der
kinder- und jugendhilfe jetzt eine
reform auf den weg zu bringen
die im fokus sieht die kinder und
jugendlichen und deswegen freue ich mich
und freuen wir uns auf eine breite
diskussion mit den verbänden mit den
experten und lassen sie uns dann in
einigen wochen wieder hier
zusammenkommen wie beim elterngeld und
einen einen guten entwurf zahlen noch
besser ein gesetz machen
das glaube ich wäre dann auch für die
familienpolitiker kinder und jugendliche
ein großer erfolg noch in dieser
legislaturperiode daran wollen wir
arbeiten vielen dank
[Applaus]
jetzt hat das wort kollegin katja suding
fdp
[Applaus]
herr präsident liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen in deutschland leben etwa
240.000 kinder und jugendliche bei einer
pflegefamilie oder in einem heim
sie wurden von ihren leiblichen eltern
getrennt war diese nicht für sie sorgen
können oder noch schlimmer weil diese
sogar eine bedrohung für sie sind dass
es dann unfassbar schweres schicksal
dass diese jungen menschen so früh in
ihrem leben schultern müssen
gerade für diese jungen menschen müssen
wir alles tun um ihnen ein
selbstbestimmtes leben zu ermöglichen
der staat aber legt pflege und
heimkindern seit jahren zusätzliche
steine in den weg und das ist
unerträglich und das gehört beendet
in seiner bisherigen form verpflichtet
das sgb junge menschen dazu bis zu 75
prozent ihres durch ausbildung oder
nebenjob selbst der arbeit in geldes an
den staat abzugeben so solle die
finanzierung der unterbringung im heim
oder in einer pflegefamilie
sichergestellt werden im vorliegenden
gesetzentwurf will die
familienministerin nun erreichen dass
pflege und heim kinder mit eigenem
einkommen nur noch 25 prozent davon an
den staat abführen sollen
so werbe zitat die chancengleichheit
junger menschen mit besonderem
unterstützungsbedarf verbessert brüstet
sich frau gefallen liebe frau ministerin
das ist gönnerhafte das ist respektlos
gegenüber den jugendlichen für uns als
bei demokraten steht fest die
kostenbeteiligung von pflege und
heimkindern die muss vollständig
abgeschafft werden und die gründe dafür
liegen auf der hand
erstens sie entmündigt junge menschen
auf ihrem weg zur selbstständigkeit
ich selbst habe mein erstes geld in
einem blumenladen verdient man erste
eigene lohnt das war wirklich ein ganz
besonderes gefühl auch ein
entscheidender entwicklungsschritt ich
habe gelernt fleiß und anstrengend
werden belohnt
das familienministerium lehrt
pflegekinder mit der kosten heranziehung
aber genau das gegenteil übersetzt steht
da
ist anders deine arbeit und den fleiß
werden weniger belohnt als bei anderen
und das ist eine portale ungerechtigkeit
man damals zwei uns durch die abgaben
können jugendliche auf dem weg in ihr
eigenes leben keine rücklagen für möbel
wohnungs kaution oder den führerschein
ansparen
stattdessen sind viele dann auf
staatliche transferleistungen angewiesen
der staat nimmt diesen jungen menschen
also ihr selbst verdientes geld weg
damit sie dann zum amt geben gehen und
finanzielle unterstützung beantragen
müssen das kann ja wohl nicht der
richtige weg sei man zusammen und
drittens experten gehen davon aus dass
die einnahmen der heranziehung von 25
prozent nicht einmal die kosten des
personalaufwandes decken das heißt der
staat zahlt sogar noch drauf das ist
nicht drin
das ist los und das darf nicht ihr ernst
sein die mit familienministerin gefallen
und auch das unter der angehörten
sachverständigen ist eindeutig fünf von
sieben sind für die vollständige
abschaffung des kosten beitrages fördern
wir also jungen pflege und heimkinder
auf irgend weg in die selbstständigkeit
und beschneiden will nicht länger ihre
individuellen aufstiegschancen die
kostenbeteiligung muss beck
kollege ich so den achten sie bitte
darauf dass die module die linke ist der
nächste redner sehr geehrter herr
präsident sehr geehrte damen und herren
wir diskutieren heute die reform des
kinder- und jugendhilfe rechtes seit
jahren steht dessen sozial pädagogische
ansatz unter druck neoliberale
instrumente sollen einkehren
individuelle rechtsansprüche geschwächt
und öffnungsklauseln für die
bundesländer eingeführt werden im kern
geht es darum geld zu sparen
bereits in der letzten wahlperiode hat
die groko erfolglos versucht am
bundesrat gescheitert an linken und
grünen regierten ländern
diese sozial pädagogischen ansatz ein
für allemal zu schreddern die linke
stand stets und zu jeder zeit an der
seite derer die das fortschrittliche
kinder und jugendhilfe recht verteidigt
haben und trotzdem und trotzdem gibt's
natürlich reformbedarf das wissen auch
wir die inklusive ausgestaltung ist nach
über 30 jahren kinder und
jugendhilfegesetz überfällig gewesen und
auch die nunmehr verpflichtende
einführung von ombudsstellen vor
ministerin begrüßen wir ausdrücklich
kinder und jugendliche die in heimen
oder pflegefamilien leben müssen bisher
75 prozent ihres eigenen einkommens
abgeben wer eine ausbildung macht oder
sich im ferienjob was zu verdient behält
also fast nichts
die bundesregierung will dieses
vormoderne kostgeld jetzt auf ganze 25
prozent senken
ich verstehe nicht warum diese für die
jungen leute demotivierende schikane
nicht entschuldigt endgültig und
vollständig abgeschafft wird
im gesetzentwurf wird den beteiligte
rechtliche schlechterstellung von
familien kindern und jugendlichen
enthalten
ich will dies exemplarisch an der
sogenannten sozialraumorientierung
verdeutlichen
damit wird ermöglicht individuelle
rechtsansprüche auf hilfen zur erziehung
zu versagen und in den sozialraum zu
verweisen
zur sogenannten niedrigschwelligen
angeboten statt einer individuellen
familienhilfe wie bisher können
betroffene familien beispielsweise auf
eine anlaufstelle der jugendsozialarbeit
ein gruppenangebot in der schule
oder einen kurs im familienzentrum
verwiesen werden um nicht falsch
verstanden zu werden
jugendclubs street wird ganz auf
ganztagsangebote in schulen sind total
gut unterstützen wir auch aber sie
ersetzen keine benötigte individuelle
familienhilfe und hilfe für die kinder
und jugendlichen auf dem ersten blick
hört sich das total gut an
dietrich wellige angebote im sozialraum
wenn aber individuelle rechtsansprüche
auf hilfen für kinder und familien
abgebaut werden dann ist das nicht
niedrigschwellig schritt
niedrigschwellig dann schleifen sie den
sozialstaat oder machen wir als regel
nicht mit stattdessen wollen wir eine
echte stärkung der kinder und
jugendhilfe das bedeutet dass wir eben
mehr finanzielle ressourcen brauchen
statt weniger in den kommunen ländern
wer kinder stärken will der muss ihre
mitbestimmungsrechte und ihre
rechtsansprüche stärken
wir wollen kinder schutz durch
präventive arbeit ausbauen
zb durch eine bessere ausstattung der
offenen kinder und jugendarbeit und der
jugendverbände wo kinderschutz praktisch
wird wir wollen den rechtsanspruch auf
hilfen für die jungen volljährigen
ausbauen da sind die formulierungen im
gesetzentwurf zu unklar
und herr kollege weinberg ich habe das
ja gut zur kenntnis genommen im
familienausschuss haben sie die anträge
von grünen und uns zur jugend
wohnungslosigkeit noch abgelehnt die
zahlen haben übernommen über 30.000
betroffenen jungen menschen die ohne
eigene wohnung leben auf kaution bei
freunden unterwegs sind oder sogar auf
der straße ich nehme das wohlwollen zur
kenntnis und die angebot ernst dass wir
im familienausschuss dazu kommen diesen
gesetzentwurf der bundesregierung
wenigstens in dem punkt zu qualifizieren
dass die bessere lösung finden für klima
und für junge menschen die ohne eigene
wohnung leben müssen in diesem sinne
freue ich mich auf den weiteren
austausch vielen dank
das rednerpult wird vorbereitet für die
kollegin ekin deligöz grüne sollen sich
die grünen herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ja wir reden
zur kernzeit aber leider viel zu kurz
für so ein wichtiges gewichtiges gesetz
was wir hier besprechen und vieles von
dem was die frau ministerin vorgelegt
haben sind überfällige änderung dem
kinderschutzbund und wir werden sie auch
unterstützen und wir wollen auch sie
konstruktiv darin begleiten dass das
ganze auch umgesetzt werden kann das mal
vorneweg gesagt will ich aber trotzdem
ein paar vorschläge
mit reinbringen und paar baustellen
benennen die uns dennoch in den
beratungen auf jeden fall in den
mittelpunkt rücken müssen
der kernbereich dieses gesetzes ist ja
der einstieg in die inklusive
jugendhilfe und das war ehrlich gesagt
tatsächlich auch fällig und die
zeitlichen abläufe die sind mir aber
ehrlich gesagt noch nicht ganz klar wir
werden darüber im verfahren reden und
damals schon meinen ersten vorschlag
natürlich kriegen wir die inklusive
jugendhilfe nicht über nacht gewuppt und
hin wir brauchen dafür auch zeit aber
wir sollten den kommunen die genau diese
große arbeit zu stemmen haben auch mehr
möglichkeiten und freiheit geben zb
durch eine experimentierklausel und
durch ein bundesmodell programm der sie
darin ermutigt und unterstützt das auch
umzusetzen
das könnte modellhaft werden für alle an
das könnte uns zeit und luft verschaffen
auch gute modelle zu entwickeln und in
der systematik auch apple guten produkt
herauszubringen
das zweite ist aber sie sagen der
kernelement ist ein leistungsgesetz das
stimmt schreiben aber gleich rein egal
was wir am ende machen
es muss auf jeden fall kostenneutral
sein ich muss mir doch erst mal
überlegen was ich will und dann gedanken
darüber machen wie ich das finanziert
kriege aber wenn ich schon von
vornherein sagen es darf nichts kosten
dann kann ich auch nicht wirklich etwas
verändern lassen funktioniert in der
form nicht geben sie uns da luft und
eine chance etwas gutes daraus
entwickeln zu lassen
die verfahrens nutzen und ombudsleuten
das ist was sie da wollen ist komplett
in wagen da werden wir ganz viele
nachfragen kriegen was wollen sie da
eigentlich das finde ich sehr schade da
sollten wir konkret sein und die letzten
zwei punkte die ich in meine drei
minuten redezeit unterbringe ist der
paragraph 4 kg
ja sie haben einen guten beteiligungs
vor dem beteiligungsprojekt er hat und
in diesem prozess haben sich alle
eingebracht aber an diesem punkt sagen
uns alle experten das was sie da rein
geschrieben haben ist nicht von uns es
wird von niemandem unterstützt es ist
komplett missglückt und ich glaube dass
da die alte fassung besser ist als das
was sie jetzt vorschlagen und zuletzt
dieser bereich der absenkung der kosten
heranziehung ja 75 prozent auf 25
prozent zu senken ist schon ein
fortschritt aber es spricht wirklich
wirklich alles dafür darauf komplett zu
verzichten ich weiß schon was sie
glauben wenn die leute mit
zahlen und beeinträchtigt würden hätte
es ein pädagogisches moment aber sie
verkennen die lage der jungen menschen
die davon betroffen sind
die brauchen andere pädagogische momente
und das hier ist es nicht
sie belegen und zulegen lassen sie uns
anwälte der kinder und jugendlichen
seien auch mit diesem gesetz und dafür
müssen wir diese baustellen aber noch
klären
[Applaus]
jetzt erhält das wort die kollegin
ulrike bahr spd sehr geehrter herr
präsident liebe kollegen und kolleginnen
seit 30 jahren haben wir in deutschland
ein gutes und modernes kinder und
jugendhilfe recht im mittelpunkt stehen
angebote und hilfen für kinder
jugendliche und ihre familien die
partnerschaftlich entwickelt werden
sollen dabei leisten jugendämter und
freie träger ganz überwiegend großartige
arbeit für familien in schwierigen
situationen aber es gibt auch
schattenseiten und problemen zum
beispiel steigende zahlen bei
inobhutnahmen großes misstrauen
gegenüber jugendämtern skandale wegen
entwürdigende erziehungsmaßnahmen und
einrichtungen der jugendhilfe eine
demotivierend hohe kostenbeteiligung für
junge menschen in pflegefamilien und
heimen aus dem ruder gelaufene auslands
maßnahmen oder ein viel zu abruptes ende
fand hilfen für gerade volljährigen
darum ist klar dass kinder und
jugendhilfe recht verdient ein update
zum einen muss die kinder und
jugendliche endlich inclusive werden
seit vielen jahren diskutieren wir unter
den überschriften große lösung inklusive
lösung oder jetzt hilfen aus einer hand
darüber alle kinder mit und ohne
behinderung unter dem dach der
jugendhilfe und leistungen zu sorgen
die sie und ihre familien brauchen etwa
360.000 kinder und jugendliche in
deutschland leben mit einer behinderung
sie brauchen gute und bedarfsgerechte
unterstützung am besten unbürokratisch
und aus einer hand
zum anderen müssen wir auch im bereich
der kinder- und jugendhilfe den
sozialstaat auf augenhöhe
weiterentwickeln beteiligung
beratung in wahrnehmbarer form
befähigung beschwerderechte sind eine
zentrale säule dieser reform und daher
ganz wesentlicher faktor für das
gelingen von hilfe prozessen der gedanke
der beteiligung stand auch im zentrum
des gesetzgebungsprozesses hier möchte
ich mich ganz herzlich bedanken bei frau
ministerin gefeilt und auch
staatssekretärin karin marx die diesen
moderation diesem prozess geleitet hat
ja die vorbereitung zur vorbereitung hat
das ministerium sex diesen
beteiligungsprozess mit verbänden
wissenschaft ländern und nachbar resorts
über ein ganzes jahr durchgeführt
begleitend gab es ein forschungsprojekt
eine online-plattform und
veranstaltungen vor ort die ergebnisse
wurden nicht nur sorgfältig dokumentiert
sondern auch im gesetzentwurf umgesetzt
das war ein großer aufwand aber er trägt
früchte
ich habe in den letzten monat mit
zahllosen akteuren auf allen ebenen
gesprochen und fast alle haben das
verfahren gelobt und begrüßen diesen
gesetzentwurf und im detail gibt es
natürlich unterschiedliche sichtweisen
auch die bundesländer haben noch eigene
initiativen angekündigt und das werden
wir im parlamentarischen verfahren alles
diskutieren klären und bei bedarf
nachbessern
im familienausschuss haben wir darüber
bereits eine sehr umfangreiche anhörung
angesetzt
ich freue mich auch die anstehenden
beratungen und die umsetzung von lange
erwarteten verbesserungen in den
leistungen der kinder und jugendliche
beim kinderschutz der inklusion und der
beteiligung
vielen dank
[Applaus]
voraussichtlich letzte rednerin zu
diesem tagesordnungspunkt ist die
kollegin nadine schön cdu csu
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen die reform des
kinder und jugendschutzes ist ein ganz
zentrales vorhaben in dieser
legislaturperiode und die vorredner sind
schon darauf eingegangen
schon in der letzten wahlperiode gab es
den versuch das kinder und jugend recht
in deutschland schutzrecht in
deutschland zu reformieren
damals kam der gesetzentwurf kurz vor
ende der legislaturperiode
er war schlecht vorbereitet wurde nicht
mit der fachwelt diskutiert und die
fachwelt hat dementsprechend reagiert es
gab einen großen aufschrei
wir haben dann im parlamentarischen
verfahren vieles einige sachen
herausgegriffen noch versucht zu ändern
aber auch das hat es nicht mehr
geschafft vom bundesrat verabschiedet zu
werden und deshalb haben wir zu beginn
dieser legislaturperiode besagt das
ministerium muss das thema ganz anders
angehen
wir brauchen einen breiten
beteiligungsprozess wir müssen die
kompetenz derjenigen die tagtäglich mit
kindern und jugendlichen arbeiten besser
aufnehmen besser hören was wollen sie
was brauchen sie um kinder und
jugendliche optimal zu unterstützen und
das hat das ministerium gemacht in einem
breiten beteiligungsprozess mit
verbänden mit experten mit einer uns
online konsultation an der sich jeder
beteiligen konnte und deshalb liebe frau
ministerin ihren und ihrem haus ein
herzliches dankeschön dafür das war ein
guter prozess und der staatssekretärin
karin maag sie das federführend
begleitet hat hut ab für diesen
erfolgreichen prozess so haben wir uns
das vorgestellt das war eine gute
vorbereitung für dieses gesetz
unter anderem gab es da auch eine
einheit für die sich marcus weinberg
unser kollege sehr stark eingesetzt hat
nämlich ein modul für hochproblematische
kinderschutz verläufe und ich bin froh
dass das aufgenommen wurde
wir haben in der entsprechenden komisch
auch eine entsprechende kommission
gründeten wir wollen dass auch die
ergebnisse noch besser in das verfahren
mit aufgenommen werden wenn wir solche
sachen initiieren dann wollen wir auch
die ergebnisse haben wollen dafür lernen
da gibts noch ein bisschen was zu tun
bester kinder- und jugendschutz die
stärken finden kindern und jugendlichen
in pflegefamilien und den einrichtungen
der erziehungshilfe hilfen aus einer
hand für kinder und jugendliche mit und
ohne behinderungen mehr prävention vor
ort und mehr beteiligen
das sind fünf bausteine und das ist
dieses gesetz aus diesem baustein
besteht dieses gesetz einige punkte sind
in dieser debatte schon heraus gegriffen
worden und auch meine redezeit reicht
nicht um auf alles einzugehen
ich will aber gerne auf den punkt
eingehen der heranziehen von kindern und
jugendlichen die in pflegefamilien
wohnen aus ihrem ersten einkommen sei es
der ferienjob sei es das erste
ausbildungsgehalt ja bisher war es so
dass sie dies abgeben mussten und das
finden wir für ungerecht
als unionsfraktions setzen wir uns schon
lange dafür ein dass wir an diesem punkt
etwas ändern es ist demotivierend für
die jungen menschen wenn sie das erste
selbst verdiente geld abgeben müssen und
deshalb brauchen wir hier dringend eine
änderung
das wurde aber auch in diesem
beteiligungsprozess diskutiert und dort
kann man mehrheitlich zur auffassung
dass es richtig ist 25 prozent abzugeben
warum weil auch kinder und jugendliche
in familien ganz oft von ihrem ersten
selbst verbinden ausbildungsgehalt ein
bisschen was an ihre eltern abgeben wenn
sie noch in den familien wohnen einfach
als zeichen dafür dass man sich
beteiligt an den täglichen kosten an der
miete an der verpflegung das ist in
vielen familien selbstverständlich und
eine ganz bewusste maßnahme auch
gegenüber den eigenen kindern und
deshalb war das mehrheitsvotum auch in
dieser beteiligungs kommission dass man
das natürlich deutlich reduziert aber
dass man den kleinen kostenanteil doch
noch weiter gelten lässt und deshalb
finde ich die regelung nicht so und
sozial wie sie das wir darstellung frau
suding und ehrlich gesagt habe ich mich
gewundert dass gerade von der fdp dieses
kritisiert wird wir
ich finde es gut und wichtig dass wir
uns auch die situation der care lieber
noch mal vorgenommen haben es ist eben
nicht so dass mit volljährigkeit die
hilfe beendet wird hier brauchen wir
mehr sicherheit und mehr unterstützung
auch gerade beim übergang in die
selbständigkeit und ein punkt mit blick
auf die redezeit der mir besonders
wichtig ist würde ich noch erwähnt dass
in die kinder aussucht und psychisch
kinder von sucht und psychisch kranken
eltern diesem bisher das raster gefallen
weil sie selbst ja nicht süchtig waren
weil sie selbst nicht krank fand sich
selbst vielleicht noch keine
verhaltensauffälligkeiten haben mit
diesem gesetz packen wir das thema an
ein thema das wir als unions fraktion
seit jahren vorantreiben mit einer
kommission die das aufgearbeitet hat wir
haben dafür gesorgt dass es auch in
beteiligungsprozess eine große rolle
spielt und jetzt schaffen wir ein system
dass diese kinder schon sehr früh auf
hängt mit beratung mit unterstützung mit
besserer zusammenarbeit der ärzte und
das
ein gutes signal für diese kinder die
wollen wir nicht aus dem blick verlieren
die wollen nicht verlieren
mit diesem gesetz werden wir sie
auffangen und auch dass es ein gutes
zeichen stehen
[Applaus]